[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down
Oppenheimer the movie is now out on 4K
and digil so I thought I'd go back
through the film and break down the real
life history hidden details and all the
things that you might have missed in it
Nolan really put his all into this
entire film and at the moment it's his
longest running movie clocking in at 3
hours the IMAX reels for it were 11 M
long and they even invented special IMAX
cameras to film the black and white
scenes in order to keep the quality of
these in line with the rest of the film
Kodak also produced dou XX black and
white films stalk in 70 mm the film
stock itself actually mirrors the super
XX sold during World War II which was
the most popular brand amongst
photojournalists now the film is based
on the book American Prometheus which
Chronicles oppenheimer's life originally
optioned to Sam Mendes shortly after its
2005 release the writes to picked up
notable interest over the next 15 years
Oliver Stone was also involved at one
point but it was was 2019 that saw Nolan
jumping in during the production of
tenet Robert patson gave him a book of
oppenheimer's speeches in which he
wrestled with opening Pandora's Box
Oppenheimer of course gets brought up in
tenet as they approach the first atomic
test Oppenheimer became concerned that
the detonation might produce a chain
reaction anding the word and it sort of
leads perfectly into the themes of this
movie Prometheus of course also comes
from ancient myths with him being the
person that gave fire to The Mortals in
doing this he defied the gods and gave
humans a that they weren't quite ready
for the movie actually has a quote about
this story L throughout the opening and
it talks about how he was tortured his
punishment for doing this Oppenheimer is
also tormented as well with his
reputation being destroyed by those he
closely trusted he also had to deal with
a Gil that creating a device like this
cause with it sort of being a punishment
cast down by higher power Nolan said his
first encounter with Oppenheimer came in
sting song Russian in which he said how
can I save my little boy from
deadly me I first seen him during
Jurassic Park where he could spot him by
Dennis nre's computer that also had a
mushroom cloud on a Post-It note with
Spielberg choosing this for a specific
reason he wanted the dinosaurs to be
something that could destroy Humanity
through signs which shows the kind of
thing that Oppenheimer represents now
Nolan Oppenheimer is being a
misunderstood figure who is filled with
regret over what he'd Unleashed
instantly this hooked him in and he
began crafting the screenplay when
looking at the film there's a ton of
symbolism for things going on at the
time with us very much getting a cold
war between stros and Opie stros to me
very much represents the Russians who
became enemies of the West due to
secrecy and paranoia Oppenheimer and
Einstein they interact in a way that
makes them think they're talking about
him which in the end leads to him trying
to tear down the former's reputation the
Soviets of course were never given
access to the bomb and then being shut
out caused them to take drastic measures
strw shows how feeling shidow can lead
one to operate nefarious ways which
we'll talk more about as we get further
into the video now the movie very much
operates with the beginning and end that
mer and we begin with upen Heimer
watching raindrops in a puddle come the
final shot this is also what he stares
at in the leg only this time they
represent the mushroom clouds of nukes
in wondering about these rain drops as a
student that causes him to be plagued
with visions of things he doesn't fully
understand into out with these moments
we get shots of the Trinity test which
we later see is based around the world's
first nuke this happing shot very much
Sparks of a chain reactor ction that
then leads into the nihilism that we get
at the end Oppenheimer wondering this
then leads to the creation of the bomb
which then puts it out into the world
out of his control in the end as he
watches the rain hitting the pond it
makes him realize he may have
inadvertently destroyed the world in the
film they discuss whether the chances of
igniting a bomb could satellite the
atmosphere and destroy our entire planet
though that didn't happen in that
instance opheim and now realizes that it
could still come down the line the
entire movie itself is somewhat of a
ticking time bomb with these opening
rain drops leading up to that as we know
the protests did not make a hydrogen
bomb they fall on deaf years and now
humanity is in an arm race to create
bigger bombs this in itself could Wipe
Out the entire world and it's something
that one character represents in the
film that is enrio fery who's played in
the film by Danny De Ferrari though he
doesn't get a major part in the movie
his thinking is actually play to the
film's ending in a big way so far we as
humans we haven't found any signs of
intelligent life elsewhere in the
universe unless you count those Mexican
hearings that showed off aliens however
firy theorized that there may have been
Advanced civilizations but eventually
they hit the point of their own
self-destruction he believed that
potentially once a life form gets to a
certain point they'd start to build
weapons that just got bigger and bigger
and bigger eventually this would lead to
them destroying themselves and thus this
is why there's no other signs of
intelligent life it really plays
perfectly into the film's final scene
and makes you realize what oppenheim is
really wrestling
with
now I also found it a bit symbolic that
we begin everything with the world which
itself is the universal logo Nolan was
originally with Warner Brothers for this
but after the day and dat proposal for
HBO Max he then move Studios the film
itself somewhat Echoes that frustration
with the higher ups ignoring the outcry
of the actual creators at the bottom the
movie itself is broken up in black and
white and also color scenes structurally
it's to non chronologically with there
being several chapters that recount
moments from his life Nolan stated the
black and white scenes as something
that's objectively true whereas the
color ones there far more subjective the
first of these chapters is titled
fishing and it basically recounts
oppenheimer's entire life the second is
called fusion and it centers around STW
trying to become Commerce Secretary this
takes place at a senate hearing and also
introduces Alden arich's character he's
just known as Senate to Le stross and as
I'm sure you can guess this guy's made
up with him being the only fictional
character in the film it's important to
bear in mind that all of stross's
perspective is shown in black and white
and this represents how the character
sees the world all he wants to do is
create more weapons R Oppenheimer stands
as an a front of this Oppenheimer on the
flip side gets his scenes in color
showing more of the nuances of how he
views the world fusion and fish also
represent the reactions created in order
to set up these bombs with them
colliding atoms in the same way stross
and Oppenheimer but heads early on
stross is told this is just a formality
with his confirmation being all but
assured in the end though he was lied to
as well which reflects how Oppenheimer
was scrutinized by the higher-ups now at
oppenheimer's school we see our first
major part in American Prometheus which
involves the poisoning of one of his
teachers apples in the aftermath of this
rpie faces regret and tries desperately
to undo this before it causes damage
this of course is a metaphor for the
nuke in which he carries out something
that could take other people's lives
clearly remorseful he then tries to take
it back which foreshadows how he acts
with with the weapons later on now this
Apple is very much a point of contention
with his grandson Charles questioning if
it happened he said that was a problem
in American Prometheus if you read it
carefully enough the authors say we
don't really know if it happened
unfortunately the biography summarizes
that Robert Oppenheimer tried to kill
his teacher and then they acknowledged
that maybe there's this doubt now though
it might not be real it is a thing about
the real life figure that's gained a lot
of publicity personally I think it works
well for the character in the film and
shows that he often acts drastically
without thinking of the consequences
then in the aftermath it plays on his
mind and he does whatever he can to try
and wind the clock back apples of course
also carry a lot of symbolism with them
representing knowledge in the Garden of
Eden and apples also what fell on Isaac
Newton's head and made him realize the
truth about gravity in the movie it's
almost eaten by his Idol nil bore who in
this film's played by returning nni
Kenneth Brer nni dear me now Oppenheimer
he's also told to tidy up so he misses
the St of his lecture and he begins by
being [__] out by the authorities which
foreshadows his fate later on the next
day B asks Oppenheimer if he can hear
the music and at this point the score
starts to play this is composed by LV
Goron who also worked with Nolan on the
movie tenet and zma was originally down
to doing both but he committed himself a
June part one and two Nolan didn't want
the music to sound like it was from the
military and thus they scale things back
to use more classical sounds because of
this it doesn't feature any drums at all
uh unless you count my man Jack quaade
who's playing out with the Bongos now
this is because he's playing Richard
fainman Who in real life was a prolific
Bongo player aside from that though the
pece comparing mats of music that
actually has 21 separate Tempo changes
according to IMDb trivia ludvig wanted
to record it in segments due to how
complicated the music was however with
some convincing from his wife they used
specialized techniques to record it in
one take B says you can lift the stone
without being ready for the snake that's
revealed this is is a warning that
Oppenheimer ignores because
unfortunately War pushes him towards
having to make the weapon upon asking if
he can hear the music we then cut to
shots of clouds which we see a repeat of
at the end of the film this time it's
filled with nuke's taking off showing
the future that he might have ushered in
openen Heimer blames the apple on having
a wormhole which is also a term in
physics that Nolan's used before
Interstellar had its whole plot based
around one and the Apple itself is kind
of like him getting sucked into a
wormhole of death and
destruction
great now for this video we've teamed up
with exter who get you better gear for
life on the move at the moment they're
running a big Black Friday sale and then
one for cyberweek next week where in
both they're giving away 50% off and an
extra 5% off by using our code below now
in case you don't know ex to sell range
of wallets bags and cases and
accessories to help your life on the go
right here I've got the pot wallet it's
minimalistic really Compact and it's got
this trigger function as well that makes
all your cards pop out every single time
they pop out that looks cool I
absolutely love doing that it just keeps
things nice and tidy you look smart and
I think this is a really good product
that I definitely recommend you pick up
this gray is the parliament wallet but
they've also got smaller ones as well
where it's just your card so you can pop
in and out and yeah really makes life
easy they've got an extra pocket for
cards in cash yeah they can hold up to
12 cards and on top of this they're
extra secure it also blocks RFID
Wireless theft and comes in a range of
color so no matter your luck you're
going to look amazing on top of this an
extra that I really love is the wallet
tracker card they've got a worldwide
lost and found Network so no matter
where you leave it you can instantly
track it down and off just 3 hours of
solid charging it can last for a full 2
months all you have to do is just leave
this in the Sun for 3 hours you've got
two months of coverage so you never need
to worry about it it's also credit card
size voice activated by using Siri
Google or Alexa and it also fits snugly
into this and straps onto your wallet Bo
nice and easy and yeah you've got it on
the go this is the one I've mainly been
using at the moment cuz it goes with a
suit you know I've been going a lots of
weddings recently uh so I really love
that but I also picked up the black one
as well cuz I like to mix a match like I
said they've got a massive Black Friday
sale on at the moment another one during
cyber week and in both you're going to
get 50% off by visiting the website but
on top of that an extra 5% by using my
code and clicking the link below my code
is heavy spoilers I'm sure you can guess
it heavy spoilers just click the link in
the description use that code and you're
going to get up to 55% off makes an
amazing gift I absolutely love this so
whether someone's birthday's coming up
you know Christmas is right around the
corner and you want to get shopping
definitely pick one of these up nice
safe and secure very sleek and smart and
yeah huge shout out to them for
sponsoring the video thank you now from
this Pony visits in our Gallery where we
see Picasso paintings like Oppenheimer
the artist had a brand new way of seeing
things and it was surrounded by messing
chaos you also catch him reading the
Wasteland which is a poem by s alot
written in the wake of World War I it
talks about Mankind's continual cycle of
Destruction and two begins with
discussing the weather with a focus on
rain the message of the Wasteland is
about loss which this movie to of course
centers around the poem also contains
Sanskrit mantras which Oppenheimer also
used as part of his famous quote and now
I am become
death the destroyer of world this comes
from the bagad gar and the original
quote is time I am the great destroyer
of worlds and I have come here to
destroy all people now this has been
changed slightly in the translation but
it can still be brought across to what
the scientists did Oppenheimer somewhat
adopted this to usher in the successful
testing of a nuclear weapon and the
context of it carries a lot with it this
is clearly a man showing remorse and
regret about the damage that this
seemingly great achievement could now
bring the world this point we then see
as he meets struss who corrects him on
his name's pronunciation I'm president
of Temple Emanuel and man
STW is just a sudden pronunciation St is
doing this to downplay his Jewish roots
Raz Oppenheimer proudly Embraces them
after all he was trying to fight what
Hitler's forces stood for and
anti-Semitism actually led to Germany's
downfall at the time Hitler had Outcast
lots of amazing Minds in the country
because they'd been described as doing
Jewish science this is why people like
Einstein they ended up having to flee
and it definitely led to Hitler losing
out the Germans ended up using the
scientist Heisenberg but even he was the
victim of ideological attacks due to his
appreciation of people like Einstein and
B's work he was labeled as a white Jew
in the pressent papers investigated by
the SS for a year he was actually saved
by his mother who happened to be a
friend of Hinrich him's family this
allowed him to continue working as a
scientist and he traveled through the US
studying nuclear fishion now Heisenberg
actually never considered fleeing his
country even though he was offered
teaching appointments in America it said
that he was devoutly led to Germany and
completely refused to turn against his
homeless land you have to remember that
Heisenberg grew up in a time in which
his country was still reeling from the
loss of the first world war there was a
great sense in building the country back
up and thus he refused to turn his back
on it he'd already seen what the world
had done to Germany and ended up
pledging his allegiances to Hitler he
meet Heisenberg early on in the film and
never see him again even though he's a
big driving force Oppenheimer is
constantly racing against him but during
his research he made a critical mistake
even when the two-year Head Start
Heisenberg focused primarily on hard
water which caused the experiments to be
even more dangerous boiling water that
turned into a fire that torched his lab
and on top of this Hitler he simply
didn't trust him he actually withheld
funding from his lab whereas the US they
went all out with it this cost them two
billion at the time which adjusted for
inflation is an insane amount that I
can't even pronounce the US also even
considered killing Heisenberg and they
sent out an assassin known as mberg
mberg was actually a famous American
baseball player that got drafted into
the Secret Service during the second
world war this was documented in the
movie The Catcher was a spy which also
contains his mission with Heisenberg
Heisenberg went out to Switzerland to
give a lecture and Berg tailed him there
and then went to the lesson He was
ordered to kill him if he said something
that hinted at them having developed a
bomb and according to the stories he
Then followed him home Heisenberg
apparently thought Mo was the SS and
said if they wanted the bomb then they'd
have to back off this confirmed to Berg
that he of course hadn't made it yet and
thus The Kill Order was never carried
out after this Heisenberg made a little
progress and it was during this time
Germany started to get invaded in the
end the scientist was captured and in
the wake of the war he became lorded
like a hero this was very much in
opposite to Opie and in many ways you
could say that they were opposit
terrible but Heisenberg he he actually
claimed he didn't develop the bomb on
purpose and sabotaged the studies so
Germany wouldn't win whether that's
really the case I'll I'll leave that up
to you but Oppenheimer orza has an enemy
in struss I do kind of feel bad for him
cuz initially he starts off by being
friendly but Oppenheimer sort of looks
down on him and he feels Bel by this he
says his father was just a shoe salesman
and describes himself as a self-made man
which Oppenheimer says he can relate to
however it was his dad who did all the
work with Oppenheimer getting a head
start in life whereas struss didn't this
is why he sort of hit his identity and
enforced his name's pronunciation in the
end this just causes a wedge which is
made worse when Oppenheimer meets up
with Einstein Einstein can be seen
throwing a stone and in German his last
name it literally means Stone the water
being the planet could also be
represented here with his research being
like throwing a rock that creates chaos
doing this and blows his hat back which
kind of symbolizes a Bomb Blast almost
like the rock caused it I'm I'm trying
to here I'm trying to hear analyzing
don't don't play the reach clip again
now in the end Einstein ignores stross
and Oppenheimer isn't Blown Away by the
job offering that's why I'm considering
it this makes paranoia grow within him
because he he thinks it could be him
that's caused the issue he also suspects
something might be up and it's fear and
paranoia that causes his downfall and
they didn't concern you just then I was
entirely consumed with what he must have
said to Einstein to saour him on me Al
so we see Oppenheimer can speak other
languages which STS as a mark of the
character's Intelligence on the train he
meets Isidor rabi and we see the anxiety
attack with a background beginning to
shake this is a motif that appears
throughout the film with it also
representing a briming chain reaction
this is something that's about to
explode with a rattling getting more and
more intense as we go throughout the
film The shaking and the shots of fire
are Lac throughout the movie with it
eventually being revealed that this is
in fact the Trinity test this sort of
feels like it's the start of a chain
reaction but there's also something lace
throughout the edit that's the sound of
stomping feet which is later revealed to
be at the speech where oppenheimer's
mind changes this gives the soundtrack
you know the feeling like it's sort of a
runaway Locomotion and like obby's ideas
it now can't be stopped now Berkeley we
also meet Dr Ernest Lawrence who's
played by none other than your boy Josh
Harnet this is something that's sort of
a full circle moment as Harnet was
almost cast as Bruce for Batman Begins
apparently haret ended up declining it
though which he since said is a big
regret the film is of course filled with
lots of familiar faces and it basically
makes this into one big Ensemble piece
noan actually said he cast this on
purpose because he wanted all the
scientists to be distinct and faces that
we'd remember often times if you don't
know the cast well a lot of them can
sort of just blend into the background
I'm looking at you Alien 3 yes I know
you guys now I'm I'm talking about when
I was 10 mate and it was 20 different
people with shaved heads I didn't I
didn't own n Years anyway he says Theory
will get you only so far and up andhe my
aveng he has to put his ideas into
practice that's the difference between
the fishing and fusion chapters with a
former being Theory whereas aad isn't
however we see the damage that it causes
and you wonder if things should have
just stayed in the classroom but once
people start hearing what you can do
with it there's no going back hey his
class starts off with just one student
but the numbers increase almost like a
reaction teaching the class in a circle
he somewhat looked upon almost like a
god and I was wondering this if this was
also the structure of an Adam might be a
reach but one of the main attractions of
Oppenheimer it was of course his
celebrity but this is also what ended up
putting him in the crosshairs talking
politics in the classroom at this point
we also hear about the American
Revolution this is America AR we we had
a revolution now according to IMDb
trevia philosopher man can compared
Benjamin Franklin to Prometheus because
during this time he was doing
experimental research with electricity
in between this we see leis St who
mentions the FBI taking photos of
license plates at parties this is
something that gets touched upon later
on with a character bringing up Senator
mcarthy McCarthy was an extreme
anti-communist who went after those that
were suspected as being part of the
party he levied wild claims against
people and labeled them as traitors
which often destroyed their careers even
without evidence most of those he
accused hes left them blacklisted from
work even though they were often later
found not to be connected this is
something we experienced with
Oppenheimer and stros using his name
also hints at his tactics going to a
communist meet up with his brother Frank
it's at this place that he also meets
hon chaler hon is one of oppenheimer's
allies but he ends up trying to pressure
him into giving up Secrets this again
could be some Soviet symbolism with the
Eastern West initially being friends
however when it came down to secrets
that's when the Friendship started to
fall pot after this was brought to light
chaler lost his job and moved to France
due to his struggles finding work he
only returned to the US to attend his
daughter's wedding and he died in Paris
during 1983 here Oppenheimer talks about
what happens to stars when they die and
how violent black holes are created as
they implode this creates a gravity well
and it's so concentrated that it
swallows everything around it even
including light the bigger the star the
more violent its demise metaphorically
this can be applied to oppenheimer's Arc
with a character becoming a star
throughout the film hon says the bigger
the star is the more brutal the downfall
which we also see reflected in him later
on when they go to the site where lost
Alamos will be we see Oppenheimer
discussing this and even get an example
of the light being sucked in there like
a kind of hole in space is Frank okay
now it's at this party that he meets
Jean tatlock a tragic figure played by
Florence Pew when Nolan approached her
he said it wasn't a big role but she
said she'd happily play an extra just
for the chance to work with him now
tatlock wasn't the only person that he
had an affair with and Oppenheimer was
also involved with Ruth Talman this is a
character who we don't get much focus on
but their time together is very well
documented tlock uses op's fasination
with Sanskrit and I have to admit yeah
watching him watching him say the famous
quote as he slips it in I was like
shouldn't be doing this he basically
says now I am become death the destroyer
of girls which I wasn't expecting going
into this film however what I think
Nolan's trying to do is show this quote
symbolizes the initial start of a path
of Destruction later it's used to
suggest a chain reactions being sparked
up that could potentially destroy our
entire planet here it's used to stud a
chain reaction that in some ways leads
to Jean's death now she would later end
up taking her own life however there's
several shots that suggest otherwise one
of the cuts shows a gloved hand pushing
her underwater and this could suggest
there's other ways to look at it tatlock
was of course involved with a communist
party and many experts have speculated
that she could have been killed Jee ate
a full meal before her death which is
something people rarely do before
carrying out this act the autopsy was
also also very Bare Bones with it not
really investigating exactly what caused
her death in the film when she goes to
the book she discusses psychology and
tatlock actually went on to become a
psychiatrist her friends stated that
because of this she'd be able to handle
her depression and thus not go through
with what she did in the end that's kind
of kind of one of those things you can
debate back and forth and I guess that
it's going to remain a conspiracy
however there are several medical
experts who discounted the alleged
reports with many of them saying that if
they wanted to cover up a murder then
this is how they do it at this point we
jump back and forth between timelines
and learn that the atom has been split
in Germany during this we get a quick
cut of things spocking up which shows
the chain reaction is now continuing a
man from hereditary runs off to do it
while Oppenheimer writes out the
equations on the board he deems that
it's impossible but as We Know it did in
fact happen this shows Theory can only
get you so far and thus Opie determines
the next step will be building a bomb
metaphorically we can also see the
beginnings of a chain reaction when it
comes to his political issues attending
a group meeting he's lorded as a star
but just like the bomb this blows up in
his face we then see his newspapers
report that Germany's invaded Poland and
this was actually discussed by
historians who studyed the chronicle at
the time that had the feature appearing
on page two but here Nolan's taken some
artistic license s to place it on the
front with it also foreshadowing
Hitler's death in a quote that tells the
future of what would happen now he also
sees he meets Kitty as well with Ruth
coming in the room she walks around
skirting on the outside of them with her
also metaphorically being on the edge of
their relationship too man uses signs
talk to woo her and though she's married
he still goes after her taking her out
to Los Alamos we learn that her first
husband died trying to help the Spanish
Revolution and she deems it as being a
political move that really led to
nothing this is why she refuses to take
part in the parades later on because she
sees a transparency in how flaky
politics are now we cut to Oppenheimer
holding another meeting which is
interrupted by Edward Lawrence Lawrence
goes off on him and it somewhat
foreshadows how his friends would feel
about his politics later on at str's
hearing we learn about bordon writing a
letter to the FBI and this is due to him
reading upen heimer's file we later
learn that this was given to him by
struss who really didn't want to be
caught holding the knife this ultimately
proves to be his undoing and the SP B
that starts up the reaction that ends up
destroying him now oppenheimer's
politics are overlooked and in the end
he's accepted into the program however
this workload causes a rift in his
family and he has to drop his child off
at hkin at this point we then meet
Groves who's played by m sorry M I'm
sorry if you're watching this I do like
you as an actor I can't help myself be
making a fool of myself sometimes and
but when meeting him the pair talk about
how Nobel was famous for making dynamite
and the story is that a news paper
accidentally printed as aiter reading it
and realizing that because of the
destructive power he' unleashed his
legacy was going to be that he would go
down as a monster thus he decided to
only do positive things and in the end
the Nobel Peace Prize was created so you
have the job now uh I'm considering it
that Aon was actually in the middle of
taking a break from acting with him
joking to his wife that he had one
condition that would be if Christopher
noan called he'd end up going to work
and as we see the man returned to work
Damon said he was pretty shocked when he
got the script as the entire thing had
been written in first person on top of
that it was also on red paper which is
something he said that he'd never seen
before now Groves wanted Los Alamos out
the way and kept things highly secure
and private at all times fainman was one
of the few allowed to leave and that's
because his wife was suffering from
tuberculosis and stationed out in
Albuquerque almost everyone else was
strictly controlled though including
Edward Teller who's played by Benny safy
he's the one who theorizes that a chain
reaction could lead to atmospheric
ignition which makes upen Heimer then
race out to Einstein at this point he's
shown walking with Kurt gold Who in real
life used to take long walks with him
the pair were both friends at the
institute for advanced studies and it's
a nice touch that kind of paints him
almost like a like a wondering wise old
man that gives people advice now the
location with Einstein it's very
important and it's shut at the lake
where they later discuss this again I
love how Nolan reuse his spot as being
where it's discussed both times is a
perfect way way to bring things full
circle Raby also talks upen Heimer about
how he doesn't want to be involved in
creating a weapon of mass destruction
and how bombs fall on both are just and
unjust this is at the heart of the moral
debate of Oppenheimer but he states that
if the Germans do it first then it's
going to be way worse told to stop
wearing the uniform we then see him
suiting up which Nolan purposely shot
similar to how he did with Bruce in
Batman Begins he said he wanted to give
the idea that he was becoming an icon at
this point and the legendary figure that
we of course know from history now from
here oppenheimer's sons return but he's
also proposed with beaing secrets to the
Russians there's actually a hidden
detail in the scene and if you look at
the curtains you can see a plant leaf on
them these leaves belong to the genko
tree and a group of them were also in
hoshima famously they managed to survive
the bombing and have become somewhat of
a landmark at the location now that
stands as a testament to survival now
fromia the family move out to Los Alamos
with a scientist discussing the biggest
explosion in human history his happen in
1917 with a cargo ship carrying
Munitions beside a harbor we see the
blast edited over the top of this with
debris hitting the water creating
ripples again this calls back to that
creating a chain reaction and that had
to happen in order to lead into what we
get with the nukes now we see them
filling glasses with marbles and this is
to demonstrate all the materials needed
this is when it gets referred to as a
bomb but Oppenheimer corrects it by
calling at a gadget this is actually an
important distinction because a bomb is
of course synonymous with the ruction at
the 1 hour 34 Mark we you also see this
on a poster demonstrating how the
terminology was used the gadget's just
more of a scientific term that isn't
necessarily thought of as being a weapon
the bomb itself would also end up being
called the gadget and Nolan used the
word gadget for the film's working title
interestingly did you know that Return
of the Jedi had the name blue hav well
I'm sorry I'm not not Mr Sunday movies I
wish I was uh but moving on now from
here they then meet fukes who we later
learns the one that leaked the info to
the Soviets fukes was actually a spy for
them long before the Manhattan Project
started and the fact he kept doing it is
what got him caught even after things
had settled down he kept passing on
Secrets which led to his capture and
conviction during 1950 sentenced to 14
years he only served nine and died in
1988 43 years after the building of the
bomb now in go with this is the year
before he was convicted and we see strw
out in 1949 this is some questioning how
the Soviets built their bomb so fast
with a Purp ly building off the back of
fuch's introduction to let us know who
did it str's adamantly now have to build
the hydrogen bomb because that's a thing
that's going to put them ahead all it's
going to do though is lead to escalation
which is a theme Nolan's tackled in his
films before this is something that
Gordon touched upon during Batman Begins
in which criminals would get better
weapons to outdo the cops Batman was
seen as The Next Step Up which would
then lead to mass criminals running
through the streets there Batman he he's
basically the bomb and now the rest of
the world will have to match America by
creating more powerful weapons
eventually we'll hit a point where we
have a world ending device and we'll
finally take ourselves out ending the
conent spiral upwards looking at or
downwards depend on how you look at it
but either way looking at the film they
actually have a debate within it whether
it's just best to give the Soviets a
plan so there's not this Monopoly this
is something fukes actually argued when
he got caught and he stated that he gave
things up for the right reasons this was
in order to level of playing field and
it drastically changed how wars were
fought from then on we've met mainly had
cold Wars and these were done with
Espionage and through using spies and
intelligence there's always a threat the
other side could fire back so instead
most Warfare is being fought in the
shadows Oppenheimer says the atomic bomb
should make it so we never have to have
a war again and there is the argument
that it deescalate things too stuss
represents someone who believes they can
strike an Act without repercussions
which is also somewhat symbolic of how
the nuke is used we never actually see
them hitting their target and though
I've seen complain to this I think it
strengthens the movie everything is
supposed to be shown From oppenheimer's
perspective and it shows just how
removed he is from the bomb's Usage Now
had Str overheard the pwn conversation
he would have of course realized it
didn't have anything to do with him
still other shows how paranoid or in
fear can drive one to act in rash and
irrational ways knowing russer been
testing bombs causes strust to look at
up and high M even though we know he
wasn't complicit in them getting them
this is inout with Groves at the hearing
saying he wouldn't clear up in him today
which is something that he said in real
life however he also stipulated he
wouldn't have cleared anyone under the
new guidelines which were very much
brought into make copies time look more
damning from here we go back to tatlock
while cutting back and forth to the
closed door hearing they do such a good
shot here where they have Roger's head
past in front of Oppenheimer as he
starts to talk about the affair from
here we then pull to the side to see
Catherine sitting imagining her husband
and Jean having sex at one point in the
film Florence Pew appears topless and
this actually got covered up when it was
released in India Nolan made a big thing
about how he didn't use CGI in the film
but it's it's kind of funny how they had
to CGI address on you know you seen this
you could tell he was just like [__]
sake now we also meet Casey Affleck Pash
who was the first indicator of how
dangerous the US government could be
Oppenheimer stupidly sympathizes with
the Russians and says that they're not
Germany again carrying on this political
Chain Reaction Groves covered for him
and had P transferred and in real life
after the war he went to work for the
CIA he was rum to take part in their
quote unquote wet Affairs that involved
assassinations and also kidnappings for
at this point arrives and calls up
Anheim of the American Prometheus who
gave us the power to finally destroy
ourselves he tries to warn him that the
bomb will outlive Hitler and that he
should be very wary of what he's about
to unleash this is mired with him
learning of Jean's death with Kitty then
saying you don't get to commit the sin
and then have us all feel sorry for
thetically this plays into how he
portrayed himself as guilty after making
the boss which of course also fell on
deaf ears we then see oppenheimer's
perspective of the meeting with st which
is now in color though he tries to
downplay they should make a hydrogen
bomb that is also something that they
refuse to listen to intercot with this
is the stamping of shoes showing the
further Chain Reaction building up in
the aftermath of the bomb here he also
speaks to bordon who tells him of a time
in which he was flying back and saw a V2
rocket in the sky telling him he
imagines one day Rockets will carry
Warheads this plants the idea on his
head that he's going to have more blood
in his hands poy imagines himself in the
sea which also reappears at the end
explaining his worry Oppenheimer says
that he doesn't want that to happen
which in the end rubs Bor in the wrong
way we get a quick cut of the map and
see ripples of water superimposed on it
showing the deadly effects that the
nukes could have and tying back to the
water either way we discover that Hitler
has died and the scientists are debating
why they still need the bomb they
realize that it's going to just cause
more destruction and Opie says they need
to use it to make people fear and
respect it again it's taking the the
theory into reality and showing that
sometimes you need to do rather than
just talk anyway at this point they St
building the Trinity test site and
Oppenheimer says better of my heart
threers God this is a reference to the
John Don holy Sonic 14 which it s refers
to the Holy Trinity bumping into other
scientists we discover they're putting a
petition together to stop it even though
they petitioned to build the bomb this
was because they thought it was going to
be used on Germany but now they've seen
firsthand how it's already out their
control from here we go to Simson who
stops Kyoto being a Target and that's
purely down to him and his wife
honeymooning there this shows the
bureaucracy of war and how the higher
ups are so detached from it they don't
understand the horrors that those on the
ground will feel and to them it's just a
Target to be ticked off of a list I
can't even imagine what it would be like
being around as the blast melted off
your skin but with him he's just
thinking about how he had a nice holiday
there now there's always going to be the
debate over whether they should have
actually dropped the bomb which also
plays in oppenheimer's anxiety by the
time it came to getting used on Germany
they had been defeated and Japan itself
was on its last legs this has made
people debate whether the two should
have been dropped but Oppenheimer
realizes that these weapons are built to
be used the Curiosity with a hydrogen
bomb may get the better of us and though
so far it's only been tested if a
country gets to a point of losing a war
badly they might just fire one off now
interestingly Japan's only mentioned by
name in the film after the defeat of
Germany I think this was done for a
specific reason and for the entire film
they were focused on that with the
Japanese not even being considered but
they still have a bomb that they feel
they should use and th Japan them
brought into the conversation I take
that is the film saying that they did
need to show they had a weapon that
powerful and were more looking for a way
to strike fear into others instead of
actually using it for piece Grove says
they have to drop two because they need
to show that they have one and the
others to show that they can just keep
on doing it Oppenheimer argues it's
going to Kickstart an atomic arms race
but everyone's thinking of the shortterm
term rather than the long term at this
point we see the Trinity test and get
what's a really cool detail Oppenheimer
says they'll know if the bomb's
successful in an hour and 58 minutes and
exactly 1 hour 58 minutes and guess what
time the bomb goes off in the movie
that's right an hour and 58 minutes now
he also watches teller put some block on
his face and this comes from Fan's lost
Alamos From Below B that was apparently
something that happened at the event now
I'm sure you've seen Nolan talking about
how they did the explosion in real life
with it being the biggest one ever put
to film noan used a lot of different
techniques here and he also strips away
the sound so we just focused on the
visuals I have to admit when I first saw
in the cinemas I thought the explosion
looked a little weak I think this was
because of how I view nukes in my head
with the stem of the mushroom cloud
being rather thin however photos of the
test they actually look a lot like this
with it being thinner and a more
controlled explosion amongst this we
hear the sound of Jean and him having
sex and at this point we're then hit by
by the sound waves from this point on
the movie kind of just feels like
oppenheimer's brushed out the way with a
bomb being taken out of his control this
is celebration and we see how lack
security is with Opie getting a coded
message to his wife about the test going
well he thinks that he's the big player
now with respect Dr Oppenheimer we'll
take it from here but that's a
devastating line and shows it's no
longer under his control we don't even
get to see the buildup of it being
dropped and instead we hear her over the
radio just like Oppenheimer did this is
told to him on what I believe is August
8th which is my birthday in case you're
asking now the bombing happened two days
prior on the 6 showing how disconnected
from this St is over the top of this we
also hear Gary oldman's voice
foreshadowing his arrival later in the
film we have spent more than $2 billion
now initially there were 70,000 killed
with his being what died in the initial
detonation however however you also have
to add Nagasaki and those who are harmed
over time by the after effects in total
it's thought that over 226,000 were
affected but the true number can never
be known now from here he goes to the
hearing and sees the Applause that he's
getting for what happened amongst the
crowd is actually Nolan soda who he cast
for a very specific reason he said that
if you create the ultimate destructive
power he will also destroy those that
are near and dear to you I suppose this
was my way of expressing that in what to
me were the strongest possible terms she
also appeared during Interstellar and
was uses a way to show the distance
between him and his children when he's
working on films that was something
Cooper had to deal with too with a job
being a thing that takes him away now
this itself is staged like the radius of
an explosion with people's distance from
him determining what happens for example
those up at the front they're turned to
Ash but as we move outside we see
someone being sick this is a hint to the
radiation poisoning one would experience
on the outskirts of the blast now at
this point he sent to meet President
Truman with this being based on what
happened in real life Truman apparently
called him a crybaby and also mocked him
by waving about a tissue interestingly
the pair share somewhat similarities
which boils down purely to their middle
names when Roberts introduced he's asks
what the J stands for and Patrick
blacket then replies by saying nothing
really though the J stands for Julius
which was also oppenheimer's father's
name interestingly Harry EST Truman's
middle name s that that stood for
nothing which sort of links sort of
links them together a bit now the over
off of scenes they had to be thrown
together quickly cuz they forgot to book
out the Oval Office rooms so this was
shot at Nixon's Presidential Library
instead with them constructing a set to
make it look authentic Truman completely
forgets they bomb Nagasaki as well which
is some that's often overlooked in
history hoshima or Hiroshima depending
on how you pronounce that that often
gets the nods but it shows just how
callous the murder of hundreds of
thousands of people is his suggestion to
give Los Alamos back to the Native
Americans has also scoffed at twoo with
them wanting to keep the side to keep
building bombs in real life they were
forced off the land and Richard rhods
apparently overheard Oppenheimer saying
this which showed how he didn't want
more bombs outside he walks past the
cover of his face on Time Magazine which
was a real life cover that they based
this one off of now St starts to tell us
what happened to the others on the
project with his brother getting
blacklisted he also talks about how
linat was made to work on the railroads
this was accurate as well with it being
thought for a while Oppenheimer was the
one who dropped him in it he never
identified him though and simply feared
loyalty might be divided if Communists
and capitalists both worked on the bomb
Oppenheimer also gives a speech about
two scorpions in a jaw and how they
don't fight because the other fears that
that one could wipe them out these two
scorpions are metaphors for America and
Russia but it also represents struss and
Oppenheimer both at one point had a hand
in the other's demise and Oppenheimer
then hears that blackets put out of
paper saying nukes weren't the last Act
of World War II in fact he says they're
the First Act of the atomic war and we
cut to Black it by into his Apple
representing a combination of knowledge
and death according to STW we also see
his face on Time Magazine which too was
something that happened in real life
however for the film they made a black
and white version of the original and
that's due to the fact it was used
during the stros pot now in the end we
get the reveal that struss was the one
who had oppenheimer's security clearance
hearing with it sort of being just a
kangaroo court this was done behind
closed doors because giving him a
platform may lead to an audience siding
with his course we see more of the
damning test him and he's play out with
Lawrence at least faking illness so he
doesn't have to go his friends turn
their backs on him though which is stage
with them sitting in front of him whilst
he's discarded in the back however about
some fight in his corner and show that
the trial is indeed a Witch Hunt
Oppenheimer shakes tell's hand which
Kitty says she would have spat in his
face she doesn't do this in the end but
still shuts down his friendly
backstabbing approach not inim his
clearance was posthumously reinstated in
2022 almost 7 years after it was first
revoked author of American Prometheus
Kai bird Champion the moved saying it
now sh it wasn't something that was
going to hang over his legacy he tells
Kitty not to take the sheets in again
tying back to their code word with the
Trinity test she thinks that he went
through with a trial because the world
might forgive him if he was Todd and
feather tying back to how he acted after
the death of Jean now struss also gets
his sound in Al to after Ramy mik David
Hill turns on him in the Senate room
Malik actually made such an impact in
the short scene that he'll gained a
Wikipedia artical a couple days after
the film's release there's also the fact
that JFK denied him which sort of I
don't know it reminded me of the robin
reveal in The Dark Knight Rises
according to the history Kennedy was
originally going to vote in favor of STW
but he didn't after the whole exposure
about Oppenheimer now from here we cut
back to Einstein who warns him about
what the future is going to hold he says
that people will give him Awards but
it'll be more for them than they off for
him all it'll be done is paraded around
and this will kind of show how the
government is nice to those that helped
them Kitty refuses to shake Edward
tell's hand and this represents the true
feelings between the pair and all these
formalities in real life teller
reportedly cried over this public
rejection and never lived down what he
did to Opie either way for standing up
against the hydrogen bomb he was
completely humiliated and once the
debate was over he was then paraded
around he's no longer got the power he
once had though and he imagines the
nukes powerless to stop them on looking
at why this ending is so devastating you
actually have to look look at the man
himself oppenheim was a professor at
University that ended up making
something that killed hundreds of
thousands of people he wasn't a
politician and he wasn't a soldier he
was just a man that had a fascination
with Sciences this has led to a
devastating Discovery and now in the end
he can't put the toothpaste back in the
tube I've also found the saying I'm the
destroyer of worlds interesting because
we're talking about worlds and not
talking about cities he's well aware now
of what his invention could lead to and
that is the destruction of our entire
planet his imagination is what plagued
him as a student but now it's gone far
beyond his deepest and darkest
nightmares he's created something that
will forever be a light on humanity and
even today there's still a worry of
nukes being used now I love the
conversation that they have at the pond
CU Einstein's the only person that he
can really really relate to he's the
only man in the science community that
has the knowledge he does and he's the
only the person who also has his Fame
both stand at the pond helpless to
change the future before he walks away
just leaving Oppenheimer lost in his
thoughts at this point we see flashes of
the world being struck by weapons with
Oppenheimer sitting back in a bomber
just watching the world burn eventually
this ends with the entire world Al light
and the super fire imposed over his face
that fire of course being represented of
Prometheus with it sparking up the flame
that burned down the world it finishes
up what an incredible film with a
masterclass enacting by kilan Murphy
Murphy actually pulled off a number of
things to get himself in the rooll with
him only eating one omond a day to give
himself a COR appearance it got so
convincing that kyber visited the set
and joked about how similar he looked to
Oppenheimer this included the pair
talking as if he was real with Killian
also saying he was a big fan of his book
this likeness was also shared by Tom
County with people at Princeton jokingly
treating him like he was Albert Einstein
in the end this marked the six
collaboration between Murphy and Nolan
with them first working together on
Batman Begins since then he sted in a
number of films with this being the
first time that he's played Nolan's lead
and what a way for the pair to work
together with it now being the highest
Crossing biographical film Oppenheimer
is an absolute classic and I hope you've
enjoyed us going back through it to talk
about everything in the movie please
drop a like on the video and if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you'll get early access
to videos like this every week and it
goes such a long way to helping a out
now if you want some else to watch we've
got a video on screen right now and I
promise I'm getting back to more of
these classic movie breakdowns there's
just been so much going on at the moment
but as we go over Christmas I really
want to put my focus on them cuz I just
love making them for you guys and
without the way huge thank you for
sticking through the video I've been
your host Paul and I'll see you next
time you take care peace